et puis l'actualité politique du jour
c'est bien sûr la nomination de Gabriel
hatal au poste de Premier ministre après
plusieurs jours de suspense il devient à
34 ans le plus jeune premier ministre de
l'histoire pour nos élus locaux l'heure
est donc au bilan de l'Airborne mais
aussi à l'expression des attentes envers
Gabriel hatal si la majorité
présidentielle se félicite de la
décision du chef de l'État ses opposants
eux déplore un statut co Lucas Chopin
l'information a été confirmée ce midi le
ministre de l'éducation nationale
Gabriel hatal est nommé Premier ministre
une actualité d'ampleur nationale avec
des répercussions locales pour la député
Fabienne kolbock qui entretient
d'excellentes relations avec l'homme de
34 ans cette nomination assurera une
écoute des problématiques du terrain
Gabriel hatal
c'est un député avec qui j'ai travaillé
déjà en 2017 c'est un ministre avec qui
j'ai je travaille depuis 2018 et on a
une une très grande confiance l'un
envers l'autre je pense que l'enjeu il
est de répondre au quotidien des
Français d'avoir une vision et de gagner
ces élections européennes et je pense
que le premier ministre a un rôle à
jouer même discours dans le Loir et Cher
pour Mathilde déjonkerer Gabriel Atal
fera un premier ministre idéal c'est
quelqu'un qui effectivement est
jeune voilà qui je trouve parle à toutes
les générations qui a cette capacité
quand même à à rassembler aussi et et
avancer et surtout ce que j'aime
beaucoup c'est cette manière en fait
très franche de de parler voilà alors
parfois ça peut peut-être un petit peu
égratigé mais la seule chose c'est qu'en
fait on a besoin de ça aujourd'hui pour
les opposants au gouvernement en
revanche on regrette un cap inchangé
après avoir déploré la politique sociale
et de santé publique d'Élisabeth borne
on ne s'attend pas à une grande
différence avec l'arrivée de Gabriel
Atal à Matignon c'est un jeune qui n'a à
son à son résultat aucun aucune aucun
Act particulier je ne crois pas qu'il
est pour l'instant brillé
particulièrement nous n'avons eu aucune
aucun message sur une réorientation
entendant la l'insatisfaction dans notre
pays donc je crains que malheureusement
nous soyons repartis pour finalement la
même la même histoire que celle que nous
avons connu avec Elisabeth Bor à la
mairie de Blois historiquement
positionné à gauche on regrette le choix
politique des anciens socialistes born
et hatal le maire Marc gricour voit ici
une manœuvre politique où il n'est
question que d'image on est dans une
approche libérale je crains que on soit
beaucoup dans la communication et c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui lui est reconnu ses
qualités de communicant et c'est je
crois ce qu'attend le président de la
République pour faire en sorte qu'il est
à l'Assemblée nationale dans les médias
à la tête du gouvernement le meilleur
défenseur de sa politique prochaine
échéance dans quelques mois avec les
élections européennes dans une France
décidément fracturée sur le plan
politique